んん
うん
ん
じゃあ団地なら誰もがをもがれるとも限りませんが
ロマンを感じる人が多いと思います車僕もずっとこのあのトヨタの初力って車をずっと
持ってるんですっげいいんですよねますかねこういうクルマの助手が良くないって聞い
たことあるんですけどもうボケがぁたらいいかなぁと思って86にさせている
いきましたでここにもこういう金月やっぱりの上にこのなんか実みたいなのだったり
ホンダ北車の色赤が良かったんですけどもマッカートと目立つと思っている馬の中を赤
にしました
汚くて申し訳ないんですけどもこんなのが僕の車でございますはいで僕この車里への
大学生の時に立って ok
3年ぐらい乗ってるんですよ猛攻
車で3年乗ってあの正直に言いましょう
開きました車時代が来たと言うかっこいいヒーローに行ってしまいました
結構走ってますで東京都蛙ゲイル止めなプレ
僕結構この車でちゃん乗ってますって静岡から東京行く時とけっこうこれで一人でブン
ブンって言ったりしたので走行距離が結構入ってねそうその買い換え時かなんだか思い
つつもんけどまだ乗りたいって気持ちがあるけど色に飽きてしまっ
ってことはすぐだ一つくねはのカラーリングを変えてみようかなと思いまして
そもそも目立たないようにしてたんですけどもこういうふうに同等と車を張れてるんで
逆に目立っちゃっていいんじゃないかなということでちょっとこのカラーリングの付い
た黒から別の色に変えようと思いますでこのことはまだ誰にも言ってないのでばん
ちゃんちょっと撮ってくれるかなーとか思いつつで早速クルバーの色を変えてくれる
行動に5
と思いますね kono me
[音楽]
すごいのにフィル知らぬ間に大名城管の
ブーブー基本的には存在するああああヌー
[音楽]
ブーブー振り返っますでは
風よだ自分
宜しくお願いします
んそれをちぇるん
[音楽]
を出ますこの乙6を修理に出してから早2週間がたちました
所連絡受けでも完成したということなんで早速
車屋さんにまた来ました
めっちゃキレイ誰もまだ見たことないんでねクールな俺の真っ黒の活力はどうなって
いるのでしょうか
その真相に迫りますございまーすああ
うーむゲー
小鶴すげー
でを買ってるならもう可愛いや新人戦になるかもこれけっこう決まってるとこれは
カードのコントラスはというか
考えられた奴いたぞなんてお前はカッコイーカッコ何数を大
でかっこええ
もうあれいいいいいい
ブーバー男女がこんなこと言っ
してないと思うんで今からちょっとターゲットてからいろんな人にをのいい意味で
変わり果てた86の姿を見せて驚かせていきたいとおもいます
振って
スプラフレッツに入ります
プロデューサー
ああああああ
me
てっぱん屋なん
ん
えっ16
p います
えっベッティングや角張っていを
あっはぁどうするか分からなかった
さあここだけ見ないと思いませんでしたなんかね最近ないなってちょっと話してるよ
凧触れちゃいけないんだったらしててそういう事は超な活力ちゃんの色変えてみました
これ完全な完全だもう妖精の魂でもこれですかこれでいきますぱこれって頼んだよこれ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ